(hard rock music)
- Everyone thought that I was
doing a big thing by quitting
senior year football, but
I just thought, you know,
three years of playing
varsity was too much for me.
- Yeah, definitely is.
- Yeah.
Oh, look at this couple right here.
- Aww.
- They look like they're on a first date.
- They're so nervous.
- Yeah, they look so nervous
with each other, man.
- Oh, he-he-he, I'm so nervous,
I never go on blind dates.
- Oh he-he-he, I'm so nervous,
- That was good, oh my
gosh, okay, my turn.
Yeah, I can't believe I'm doing this.
I'm so nervous I think
I just pooped my pants.
Yeah, I definitely did.
- Yeah, I can't believe I'm doing this.
I'm so nervous
I think I just pooped my pants.
Yeah, I definitely did.
- [Girl] Wow.
- Yeah, huh.
I think that guy actually
pooped his pants.
(techno music)